today House Bill 1 called the protecting
children from gender mutilation act
finally passed the Tennessee House of
Representatives it's a legislation that
will ban doctors from giving puberty
blockers and cross-sex hormones to
children or performing gender
quote-unquote gender reassignment
surgeries on children this law which
will soon be signed by the governor and
then officially enacted will actively
save kids from one of the most Sinister
forms of child abuse the world has ever
known
laws just like it are being passed all
across the country which means not only
that countless children will be
protected from this evil but also that
the cultural tide is turning in a very
real and measurable way and that's
not something that happens by accident
now it's true as the saying goes the
culture is Upstream from politics and so
this bill in Tennessee and others around
the country are in large part of their
response to cultural changes and those
cultural changes are not incidental but
rather the direct result of work that
has been done by many people in many
places including us here of course at
the daily wire as for myself you know
that I've been fighting against gender
ideology for many years yet for much of
that time fighting
like it does so often for me for for
much of that time fighting men simply
you know talking about it and there is
value in talking about things of course
but our problem as conservatives is that
too often we just leave it there we talk
and talk and talk and we're in the
talking phase the whole time and when
that doesn't work we talk some more it
feels fruitless after a while and it is
if there's no escalation no next phase
talk is impotent if it isn't coupled
with action and so a couple years ago I
decided it was time for action and short
time later we published Johnny The
Walrus you know we've had a lot of fun
with the very hilarious fact that I'm a
best-selling LGBT children's author and
the book itself is funny and meant to be
but it also has a serious purpose it's
an actual children's book meant for
children
um which has now been read by and too
many children and which is supposed to
be in antidote to the gender ideology
indoctrination that pervades the
children's section in nearly every
bookstore in America
uh the book would go on to sell over 100
000 copies in a few months uh we were
not the first conservatives to publish a
children's book with a quote-unquote
conservative outlook on a current issue
but ours was certainly
um at least among the most successful in
that category
now when the book was published we had
already begun filming what is a woman
and in January of 2022 though the movie
wasn't complete yet we had uh filmed
enough to be sure that we had something
significant on our hands and that's when
I announced publicly that 2022 would be
the year would we wage an all-out
assault on gender ideology and I
promised that we would be dealing at
some major blows that year and I wanted
to call the shot so that people would
know that this is all part of a plan
wanted our allies to know that I want
our enemies to know that that month my
episode of Dr Phil was released and went
viral a few months later when his woman
came out took the country by storm and
then in the fall with all the momentum
we had built up we set out to expose and
shut down Vanderbilt's child mutilation
Clinic a few weeks after that report
Clinic was shut down we're holding a
rally in the state capitol uh thousands
of people were there several lawmakers
attended the rally announced that they
would work on legislation to ban the
practice in Tennessee then this week
that bill passed and now awaits the
governor's signature while similar bills
work their way through the legislatures
and many other states or in some cases
have now been passed
now
lots of people on the right talk about
fighting and call themselves Fighters
but when I say that we're fighting here
at the daily wire this is what I mean
and of course none of this is possible
without our members the films the books
the investigative work the rallies
everything else
can't do any of that or achieve any of
the victories without people who support
us and support our work and by
supporting it contribute to it
so I use the word we when I talk about
all these things because this truly is a
we operation like I said already I was
talking about this for many years but
only talking I can talk on my own I
don't need anybody else for that you
know I could just I can talk all day but
uh I needed the daily wire and all of
you to actually do all of these things
that's why your membership is so
important
and this work becomes all the more
important as the other side continues
its own escalation
so for example there's another bill soon
to be passed here in Tennessee which
would outlaw sexual performances for
children this would have the effect of
primarily Banning family quote-unquote
family-friendly drag shows and the
reason that I say it would primarily ban
those is that drag queens are the
primary ones who are most eager and
insistent on performing in front of kids
which is all the more reason
um so it's it's a little bit like if I
said that uh you know stealing is
illegal and that primarily affects
kleptomaniacs well it's not a bill that
says only kleptomaniacs can't steal but
if you have a compulsion to steal then
uh you know in a in a certain way you
might say that you're more affected by
that bill but that's because of you
that's a you problem it's your own fault
uh and it's the same thing here
so the drag queens who feel targeted by
a bill that won't let them sexualize
children well if it targets you that's
only because you have this apparently by
your own confession this uh special uh
compulsion to engage in that kind of
behavior
which is all the more reason why you
shouldn't be allowed to
but a leftist activist and drag queen it
goes by the name Bella dubal addressed
the crowd here in Tennessee a few days
ago
and uh and he he had his own suggestion
for how the opponents of this bill ought
to respond leftists on social media have
applauded this speech called it defiant
and brave and it is at least one of
those things
the former that is
um let's watch
this is an attempt to erase drag in
Tennessee
this bill will further harm trans people
who are literally just living their
lives
I need you to contact your house
representative and tell them this will
not stand tells and urge them to vote no
because if they don't
this will make public Pride illegal this
year now if you don't know we've been
having a public drag in Tennessee for
over 50 years and pride began to
commemorate the events of Stonewall
back in Stonewall we weren't allowed to
do drag it was criminalized and so what
happened when the crops came in and
tried to beat us down
we picked up them bricks and sent them
packets
the original Pride was a riot and if
this year we need to remind them that we
will fight for our liberation
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
state but whatever happens we are queer
people we are very strong and we will
rise
thank you so much
introduce myself to that is the least
southern thing that the lady can do
so to be entirely clear this Drag Queen
is calling for violence because he won't
be able to perform strip teases in front
of children anymore that's how important
grooming is to this groomer he would
rather kill than be deprived of his
right to sexualize small children but
um why is this so important to him why
can't he just be satisfied to perform
his whole weird and depraved routine in
front of adults behind closed doors
there was no movement to Outlaw drag
until you brought children into it so
why can't you just leave them out of it
the answer is partly that they that they
get a sexual thrill apparently out of
cross-dressing and dancing for kids
um it's part of the fetish for them and
they will kill to protect their fetish
because their fetish is their whole
identity that's all they have that's all
they are
that's all they've chosen to be
the other answer is that drag shows for
kids are part of their master plan for
uh indoctrinating and desensitizing the
youngest Generations they can't convince
the kids to enjoy
this stuff but they can condition them
to accept sexual perversion as normal
and uh the sooner they're exposed to it
the easier that is to do that's a large
part of the point
a third party explanation this is
essential thing to understand if you're
trying to figure out why these people
would threaten to murder others because
uh you're not going to let them strip
for children
the other part is that is simply that
they are they are raging narcissists who
have never been told no until now
we have been a disastrously permissive
culture convinced that the worst thing
we can ever say to anyone especially in
LGBT activist is no
and uh and now they've become convinced
that they have the right to never be
told no because they've never been told
no
gender ideology and LGBT activism
um is all just sexualized narcissism
anyway they've made narcissism their
entire world view
and they're reacting as any narcissist
does when you tell him no you can't do
that you cannot do whatever you want
There are rules you will follow it
doesn't matter if you don't like it your
desires do not supersede the law whether
the laws of man or of God your desires
do not supersede either
they can't handle this news they don't
know what to do with it
keep in mind these people honestly
believe that they have the right not
just to be tolerated but to be
celebrated
I've made this observation
many times but don't take it from me
here's a trans HHS official Rachel
Levine in a resurfaced video that went
viral this week
stating this point explicitly listen
you know what I like to say is you know
in terms of diversity I mean diversity
is so powerful for any organization and
diversity in all of its different
aspects including for sexual and gender
minorities
and you know you don't want to have a
tolerant environment you know gee thanks
for tolerating me I really appreciate
that um and you know an accepting
environment is good but you really want
to work on on a welcoming and even a
celebratory environment for diversity in
all of its aspects including for lgbtq
individuals and so you know Hershey
approached that
we must celebrate him he tells us long
gone are the days of leave us alone let
us have our privacy that was always a
bait and switch obviously because now
actually to leave them alone would be an
attack on them
that's an attack
it is your obligation to not leave them
alone but rather to lift them on your
shoulders like Rudy at the end of the
movie and parade them around while the
crowd cheers
this demand for celebration is again
partly a tactic but it's also a sincere
expression of their overwhelming
suffocating narcissism
for people who demand celebration and uh
and and who claim the right to do
literally anything they want up to it
including holding sex shows for toddlers
is there any wonder that they react with
such demonic Fury when we not only don't
celebrate
but actively fight against their agenda
yesterday the trans activist Aaron Reed
published a tweet uh tweet thread which
garnered forty thousand likes uh in in
which he claims that
the laws being passed in places like
Tennessee and elsewhere represent an
actual genocide against trans people
and he meant it literally even provided
the UN definition of genocide to prove
his case but but of course the
definition disproves his case but that's
not the way he sees it
it's not meant as hyperbole when these
people talk this way
they they actually see it as equivalent
to genocide if anyone tells them no if
any if any limitations
are placed on the trans activist or the
LGBT activist at all
if any attempt is made to control any of
their behavior it is genocide
murdering an entire group of people and
tossing their bodies in a mass grave is
on the same moral playing field as
telling Aaron Reed that he can't strip
in front of kids or chemically castrate
uh you know a 12 year old
and call it indeed calling Aaron Reed
him as I just did in the first place is
genocide an act of evil
indistinguishable from the Holocaust
this is what they honestly believe
and it's what happens when
self-obsession becomes identity and
identity becomes religion
and their rage only increases all the
more as they realize that this kind of
hysterical yammering along with the
threats of violence and the attempts at
de-platforming and shouting bigot and
labeling and all that
as they begin to realize that this isn't
going to work anymore it did work for a
long time but it doesn't work anymore
because they're now dealing with
adversaries who cannot be manipulated or
cowed into silence that easily or at all
and that's why I will conclude here by
assuring you you Aaron Reed and you the
drag queen threatening violence and and
the rest of your ilk that we aren't even
remotely done okay this is honestly only
the beginning
we've got a lot more in store for you I
promised you a year ago that we were
going to war here and I kept that
promise I'll keep this one too
there's much more to be done that needs
to be done
and we aim to do it
so the battle continues
whether you like it or not
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]